Jacinda Dunn the New Zealand pm has quit
saying that she has nothing left in the
tank sadly neither does a New Zealand
economy with Rising inflation and
soaring unemployment stalinda
implemented a strict zero covered policy
for the best part of two years Turning
New Zealand into the hotel California
which is unfair on the Hotel California
because at least there you're allowed to
check in during covid Jacinda reminded
us all of that crazy ex-girlfriend we
had in our 20s at the beginning she was
like Aunt isender aren't just a sweet
little girl I wouldn't harm a fly and by
the end she was going you're never going
to leave me you're going to stay here
forever you're never going to escape I
control the borders take the vaccine I'm
the only one who can keep you safe